abbiamo vinto
ok abbiamo fottutamente vinto
buona visione ho trovato la la tanica ce
l'hai le chiavi per ogni game sbagliare
a venerdì 13 ma comunque sotto che porti
sfiga secondo me io sto facendo della
madonna ma se mettono la trappola
davanti alla macchina che non puoi
mettere la batteria che trancia il piede
cosa devi fare scusami ma è un car
padroni e trovato con 8 partito a fianco
che volta va bene non ci posso credere
come se quelle cose
grazie trovate vuoi tardi che ti prendo
a queste femmine brutto per marchionne è
morta succhia perché è bello vicente
importante
visto come ben riposta l'estate sta
finendo sotto il dentro il fiume dove
vado quindi preferito comunque bari che
a sinistra e semi anno da dietro con
l'aiutare un'altra volta del cuore è
tanto questo bisogna schinardi
nonostante siamo anche a fermarmi verdi
check in aria all'interno abbiamo
rischiato al barca circolo sel a voi
design estremamente gente che gente
almeno casa quali d'amico visto l'ho
visto gente dentro juve si era visto nel
cosmo madonna generatore di alba la
prima
ecco la conosciamo è spuntato adesso in
un caso eccone un altro peccato
eccola la vis colore mickey è quasi
morto a no ma ho preso da dietro
l'albero proprio adesso è rimasto
pochissimo è comunque c'è la rapina alla
sinistra da sinistra della casa
uno è morto non c'è qui dentro dipende
se si è portatori d occhio pietro che
non possono data la forte morto
bravissimo anche quello della signora
rocce ce ne sono 205 la casa o
riscoprendo presi in testa io non li
vedo neanche figurati guardona
ok
altro paradosso di noi erano veloci ma è
una uscite uscite sono uscito dalla
catena questi qua su una moto a 105 la
casetta piccolina ma mère da 3 kg
bloccato altissimo e non solo ok morta
movimento buon gioco a tetris is your
haga dietro la roccia dietrologia 60 61
quella link temi affacci e gli ho
colpito l'ho colpito qualche volta però
è lì che che poi lasciano ma di sedere
ancora prodotto da roccia e non ne
sbagliano sono sicurissimo di casey
assis infatti forse ci vada ma non ne
sono completamente sicura lo partito mai
nato ce lo facciamo sì dai 32 morto lo
ha colpito bravissimo grande thank you
all cargo al card avete un qualcosa e
non ha voce roster 4 prima che sia
meramente per quanto mai la celebre
campano con 30 secondi ai doveri che
abbiamo tutti quanti avendo tutti quanti
parliamo questi due menti dietro data da
un occhio che siamo i nostri piedi
veniamo al gatto le palle ok in centro e
spari verso sud sud ovest un ottimo
questa posizione per me forse siamo
anche salire 240 dietro un albero c'è un
pixel 23 pronti no è stato l'ultimo
preso quello in alto no l'ho preso
grande che al momento anche l'altro
dietro la rosa visivo c'è uno dietro ora
ci dovevano prima un altro 7 alive
sembra ci sia dietro gli alberi al
signore
i ragazzi ne troviamo 556 aia non avete
un altro detto per vero occhio ce n'è
uno che andato via da sempre
eccolo mara carrozzo ancora ecco ha
mancato però niente
entrò nella roccia ragioni 10 preso ma è
un apparato uccidono occhio se tutti la
pira 4 4 2
feih1 lo vedo tutti e due là dietro
e l'ultimo luisa buono ha ritoccato si
grandi cava di tre morti e quasi cavoli
grandi che si garda perché hai fatto
thomas t 1 al 20
anche una dinamica bene mi sono pagato
bellissimo ok ci vanno via
no giocate c'è uno dietro di te evitiamo
di che raffredda me lo vedo da te lo fai
te lo fai e che ha preso meo che bella
questa casa rossa che bella era un tipo
che corriamo sparato lì erano visto che
c'era esterni mese scusami calciando in
quella occhio pietro cile vicino cioè la
casa di prove tronista casetta canada
che c'è un'arma o che sta arrivando da
te pietro occhio nella mia casa sta per
entrare
sono uscite sono state caricate e ha
bloccato in mezzo alla strada
no io sono dietro muro pietro gli savani
questo non mi ha visto non mi ha visto o
più dio devono vicini dovere e se n'è
andato mai a reinvestire la sonata
pietro ce ne sono due
ecco la macchina grande non mi hai visto
ancora questo ultimo sorridente la donna
la scuola è a tetris ciance chiunque
scalare ak chi vuole una campo pietro
pietrini facciata ma occhio che c'è
gente qua che vicente pietro no attento
che c'è onorino dietro vieni tiene
dietro di sé nardi ha trovato dietro
dietro di lettere già gli e trenta del
patrono va bene veloce ho sparato un po
di gente per registrare gli occhi non
andare lì da non andare da dietro vieni
verso di me 200 metri e che tira queste
granata è più no non lo so è uno
soggetto da un anche lui nemat mancato
bravissima uno dietro il muretto quale
ed è sotto la casa ancora sul dell'altro
esubero
a me la cosa che fa me ma io non ho
detto rega non elmo e armatura yo yo ma
talmente completamente porto di gela per
poi sparare la mia sparata lui maledetto
come il ponte dove la baia porco demonio
non ci credo ma con che fisica poi ti
porta ma quello preso anche io ci hai
capito
hai dato a tutti e due layar d'angolo 6
bombe a io sto guidando aiuto visto il
driver per berg bravo grazie grazie di
avermelo detto mi sono emozionatissimo
proprio perfetto c'è un'ora buongiorno a
caso un giorno senza un motivo a iaia
che male female forte deve valutarlo
madonna melagranata creata anche sono
vitali per terapie ischemica sono io
sono malato ma disse vorrei capire dove
se viene tokyo morto sul colpo non c'è
compagni ragazze vedo uno fermo è romano
credo che mi stavo lo vedo anch'io
aspetta d'albero eccolo velino eni
esatto stiamo vedendo abbiamo ci
spariamo
il video l'ho preso una colpito ragazzi
ci stai dentro la casa credo io seguo
tutti vicini a lasciarsi avete visti
latino e 305 vengo a tirarti su siti
copri porca vacca presso coop non riesco
a dare ai
dove no non capisco ragazzi ai ha capito
ho capito no mi hanno beccato non capivo
da dov'era allora guardate da 330 metri
ci prova mai ce la fai
chissà chi si rivede li vedo almeno loro
sono due gruppi hai avuto la patella la
padella che forte mi ha coperto
tantissimi giu ben sapendo studenti
aspettava che aspetta fammi finire i
grandi 5 quest'anno sono tra di loro
erano gli sparino mentre possiamo andare
alla casa 3 più 2 5 ci siamo 127 me ne
manca uno e diamo da casa pronto quando
vorrai vinto quella destra a sinistra
con la sinistra è arrivato no dai a
destra e ceo ai ripari le speranze su di
me se forse allora sicuro gruppo da 3 da
2 ovvero da solito perfetto perfetto
perfetto era anche finito di dire la
frase che non mi sono cagato addosso
fortissimo vabbè vabbè levo questa sua
ultima partita perché hanno target ato
tutti allora ragazzi io non so come
descrivervi questa roba senza ovviamente
esterni
all ray tipo saremmo arrivati
ottantesimo su 100 come sempre però ci è
andata bene che abbiamo amici che sanno
giocare grazie di dio
niente ragazzi ci abbiamo messo una vita
ma abbiamo vinto spero che vi sia
piaciuto come si sa di preciso momento
mi piace anche vari solo le quinte
tiziana sapresti iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]